Jewish [ __ ] demon I'm surprised you
were listening to Springsteen usually
don't like a member I like this [ __ ]
Jam I like that out I like that what
happens that it's not darkness on the
edge of town it's the other one I don't
know what the [ __ ] limit is off the
top of my head it's got that on it not
Thunder Road but the other [ __ ] one
who knows great to be here it's Monday
March 23rd the day the devil was [ __ ]
raped in the ass and spit on and [ __ ]
the ocean all that [ __ ] st. Michael [ __ ]
them up I'm hitting my main man Lisa at
the boogie down man what's happening
baby I'm sure we can had a great weekend
tell them what you did tell them what
you did I finally introduced politics
and stars i won little [ __ ] started
that he gave it like a little piece
Friday you talk to me since you hadn't
gotten off yet which happens right your
body doesn't know what the [ __ ] to do
then you gave him a little bit then the
warm started right it was awesome it was
uh he thought I was kidding you Friday
you don't like what you've been telling
me to do it for months months you've
been telling me that busting out dough
so if you make people think about [ __ ]
they're never gonna do it it's like
anything else in life hey man you should
do this yeah yeah let me think about it
I think up and then they did you know
they always come up with hi I'm right
just DOS um and then they got nowhere to
go I gonna get man for 10 minutes then
they gonna start smiling and that's it
then everybody's [ __ ] happy I didn't
even have to dos are just she she was
into it and she even asked what we did
two nights in a row and we just we
watched two things we watched dude
where's my car dude where's your car and
then we watched Kings of Comedy from
with like Bernie Mac and all those guys
from 2000 and we were just laughing at
the stupid like we were laughing
hysterically for almost all dude where's
my car because the woman who'd marry
rice Cup or whatever the comedian who
played Chloe in 24 she recognized her
and I said that she's under deep cover
deep undercover as like one of those old
Tom people so we were just laugh every
time she came on screen she's deep
undercover deep undercover
it's [ __ ] fun sometimes you know
especially when you don't do it right
and you get the giggles and you it was
kind of cool I start from kind of your
point of view a little bit because she
had never done it before she stood up at
one point she's like I don't know if I
can walk I was like you're already
walking she's like oh
great and we did we had some good food
we got Thai food was a great weekend
yeah man it's nice and light you didn't
[ __ ] kill you something never go for
cocktails wait on line and deal with
[ __ ] a lot it's a lot better than
drinking honestly there's no hangover
it's not that expensive and it's uh you
don't feel like you don't even if you
never feel sick from it every once in a
while I took too much but I would never
give her that much so no you know and
sometimes you even edible and just go do
something simple like go on Ventura
Boulevard and walk around the restaurant
row over something we after this after
this podcast on Friday we went to Jersey
Mike's did you and had a great sub what
did she have she we got the same thing
we got turkey on wheat with a little bit
of bacon and that's good right yeah old
you I did the mayo with the salt in the
pepper
it was [ __ ] tremendous no avocado no
I looked the avocado I the avocado for
me is a little bit so like I like on
burger sometimes but subs I'm not hugely
into but then we went next door they
have Rita's like the shaved Italian ice
thing from Philly
well flavor G I've never been in there
well we went on a stupid day we went on
it was like free free day which we
didn't know so there's a bigger line but
we got something it was like a half ice
half custard mixed together so it's like
kind of like a shake like kind of a
thinner shake it was really good
no [ __ ] yeah I always see that it's
really popular I've never gone in there
just because apparently it's a big Phil
you think that's what Simone was telling
me and he said people love it and and
the line was literally out the door on
Friday because like the first day of
spring is free ice day or something and
it was great we had a great time [ __ ]
great man yeah how about you how's your
weekend I [ __ ] did uh you know did
spots worked on heavy from Saturday
Sunday I went through Jitsu Friday
lifted both days took the baby swimming
Saturday you know the same [ __ ] did
a few spots did great with a I did great
over at The Improv with Greg Fitzsimmons
it's cool cuz I love with the little
main room at the Comedy Store and a
death really it was telling Ari I'm 50%
in the main room the main room is iffy
you know for me it always has I just
take the spot my god
try my best and it's like a few hundred
feet from the original room so why do
you think it's different
just it's a bigger room it's a way
bigger room it doesn't layout it feels
different it's pointed towards the west
you know at the [ __ ] comedy store the
Shing do whatever they [ __ ] call her
when Chinese people Point Fung Shui Fung
Shui it's pointed to the [ __ ]
whatever it is the the East I don't even
know anymore but it's a don't know
there's no excuses I just always have in
the back of my mind I want out they're
very high energy and they would just put
me to us halt really it was just a hole
but I don't hit listen man it's it's a
fifty [ __ ] 50 situation how long does
that like where in your mind when you
have a bad set once I get to the car
once I stood the gun was making a left
onto Laurel Canyon it was all gone they
don't give a [ __ ] anymore it's a game of
percentages it's a game of you know
you're gonna have good days they're
gonna have bad days even if you have ten
bad date ten good days in a row right
eventually gonna have a bad set you know
and you can't control it you control
them you know I did okay but it wasn't
what I wanted so right Sunday day I
didn't have a great time no I did I
can't I went out of my comfort zone I
drove downtown oh oh yeah [ __ ] yeah I
wasn't gonna take the train was a half a
mile of where it dropped me oh I think a
cab why I said just and it was easy I
just drove I went over there was 20
bucks to park and I went to EBI and it
was [ __ ] phenomenal
I stayed to the semi-finals I didn't get
to watch Gary tone I got Gary tone I
watched Gary tone and rolled twice okay
that nae tortured I saw you know Harvey
Mendez lost I saw some great jujitsu I
didn't know what the [ __ ] it was too
high level for me really a lot of Lego
which I'll even like Feith like I'm
never once you become a blue belt you
see you're allowed to go for leg locks
and heel hooks and all that [ __ ] okay
but I don't even like people's feet so
I'll never become a blue bow you'll
never play with me no I'd rather [ __ ]
have my hand cut off and have a man
touching my feet and grabbing my foot
and me grabbing his [ __ ] foot but the
star of the show was direct definitely
his little girl I don't know how old she
was and him
grace grace Dundrum from tenth planet
Bethlehem PA yeah you were telling me
about it was I mean I brought me to
tears it brought me and my emotions
everything it just it was amazing to see
this little girl little asian girl was
maybe you know the other girl had oh
maybe like by 15 pounds a little tall a
little lanky
okay and she stuck to what jujitsu is
jujitsu is for little people too [ __ ]
up big people to neutralize them and you
know and she did exactly that she showed
us the beauty of jujitsu all over again
which is if you go to the technique the
way it's taught to you and stick to it
no matter what that guy is doing he
can't stop it just the technique it's so
technical jujitsu you know when you
first start it's hard to comprehend that
you do everything from strength but the
more you go you see that everything
flows and it's all about being a very
technical you put your knee there and
you end there and she did it and I mean
she brought the [ __ ] place to a
standing ovation is it only one match at
a time oh that's one matching time to
people it's ten minute matches its
submission only and it's overtime so you
grab somebody's back in a in a seat belt
and put your hooks in and they say go
and you got to get out of it or I have
to try to submit you and you have to try
to get out of it okay so you have to
turn it into me you know without me
submitting your going for you tonight
very interesting the match is the way
heddes doing it you know and he really
knows jujitsu you know people think he's
crazy or whatever when it comes to
jittery he's got a great mind he has if
I listen to him on Rogan and he was
talking about he's after watching it yes
they have to sing Eddie
against what's-his-name and metamoris I
realized that there is a market for TV
this nights I'm going through television
[ __ ] on ESPN there's some horrible
[ __ ] programming right whether it's
about hunting and I got none again
hunters or [ __ ] poker you know there
is a time slot there is room on
television today for one hour jiu-jitsu
a week and a tournament situation ten
people $10,000 winner
that's darling allowance I just you know
it's done in [ __ ] two hours you know
they're if they can figure out how to do
it in two hours on TV every week it'd be
[ __ ] phenomenal I know I'd watch
that's so what happened what was so cool
about the about the data well they do
that the Orpheum Theatre they did it
downtown you know it was just a
different shot oh no I meant with uh
with that with that girl who won like
what was so cool about her match um that
she came from behind it was always like
she she was always a smaller opponent
but it didn't really settle it I mean
the the highlight of the match was and
her mom started yelling like she caught
us a quiet minute in the room but she
goes nuts go grace wrap this up I had no
time to [ __ ] around and mess around like
the whole room of Gentiles froze how she
said it but that's how she basically
motivated her door and at the end she
got her and that I think she choked him
and she escaped and she won then she was
the cutest little girl in the world this
is gonna change for women like this is
gonna change like I think he might after
watching it I think the reason why I got
more emotional is because my daughter
won't have to take [ __ ] I don't have
to worry about my daughter getting
manhandled
you know if you have a daughter or you
know for years women always wanted to
get women's lib but it didn't bite with
me now it's biting okay you want women's
[ __ ] lib you got to get him then get
down and [ __ ] bury him woman they're
doing it Ronda Rousey's doing it right
these women are really doing it which
it's you know I'm 52 I'm along am I
gonna be around for my [ __ ] daughter
till she's 18 19 maybe you know
sometimes I get so worked up don't stand
them my head will blow up right on the
[ __ ] stage one day but until that
time I know that my daughter I mean
that's it
it's just something empowering like it
just empowered that this little girl
just did this you know when are you
gonna put her in jujitsu do you have
enough plan I'm not gonna put her in she
has to come to me and say I want to give
it a try okay I'm not really gonna force
her onto anything how expose it to it
she'll be exposed to it you know at the
house the TV at school she'll come to me
one day and say I want to go watch it
don't take
watch it and she'll either like it or
she won't
you know kids uh you know he can't I
don't want to Pistol Pete Maravich from
my child into liking a specific sport
Pistol Pete was a player in the 70s that
was great but when biography came out
his father used to torture Pistol Pete
died from cirrhosis of the liver I think
he drank himself to [ __ ] death he was
a great basketball player but he had one
of those father's right that you've seen
him with two others I'm taller get out
there
you lost go sleep in the [ __ ] garage
you know that type of [ __ ] go
you lost though shoot free throws - you
[ __ ] win those father's they're
living their dream - their child so they
pushing them I don't want to do that I
don't want her to you know she wants to
learn Tai Chi with the [ __ ] window
it'll be a Tai Chi black notes I'm gonna
hypnotize people but I think it's good
for kids like I was I'm the least
athletic person in the world but my mom
always had me doing something I got a
soccer or baseball - no she's gonna do
something right that's that's the least
of my worries listen my and my wife
doesn't work so she could take it and
there's an activity every [ __ ] day
okay always some today I went to take
school pictures in the zoo tomorrow she
just goes to school Wednesday she goes
to a friend's house and they all watch
the kids and they jump up and down they
[ __ ] barbecue Thursdays she goes to
school Friday she goes to kitty corner
there's always an adventure looming
Saturday should go swimming Sunday she
goes to daycare over at church for two
hours and she loses her [ __ ] mind
there there's always something there
always has to be something because
everybody know idle
I don't hands are the devil's
[ __ ] workshop I hope she gets
into a martial art you know people have
opinions about martial arts I know for a
fact martial arts works why because it
worked on me it got my life together two
times so martial arts works it's a
discipline it's something you get
involved in there's something that you
become a part of and that's better than
becoming anything else I'd rather have a
child and
excuse me a martial art than anything
else her involvement in that you know I
did Taekwondo for seven or eight years I
went to I went to red belt and I'm I'm
not I don't regret not doing it not
finishing to get a black belt but one
thing my mom my mom never let me quit
anything which I think helmet has helped
me a lot like I if I was gonna stop
doing a sport I had to have something
else or even that I gotta have to finish
the season I I like I had a bunch of
friends who quit freshman football the
first couple weeks into the practices I
never played football ever and I joined
freshman year and I played I only played
like two snaps the entire season because
like they had to put you in once and it
was against the worst team and I hated I
hated every minute of it but I remember
I finished the season and it's uh
especially out here you see switching
jobs a lot and and I that's never been
me I always like I try to try to stick
things out you have to it's funny last
week you and I were having a
conversation you did your taxes yeah you
thought you're gonna go back to jail you
owed a little bit more than you
anticipated right and you didn't panic I
thought to hide it I thought that you're
gonna be able to worse than what you
wore because it's nothing you could do
but then you told me you wanted to drive
I'm like this [ __ ] guy's crazy when I
call you at my you're like I'm gonna I'm
gonna drive I gotta call you back and
you would give us some people some rides
and I thought about it that night and
Lee I've done the same whenever I get
into a bind them like all [ __ ] well
before I got into comedy even when I got
into college there was times when I said
you know what this isn't working I'm
gonna go get a job and bam you book a
[ __ ] commercial BAM you book a TV
show right and people do that all the
time right they they go for a dream and
then you know a couple years into it
like I'm not making money in this I'm
gonna go back to driving a bus and then
but if they would have put the full
effort I understand I understand man I
understand when people do that
I understand the need to have money I
understand the need to want things I
just don't understand the need of people
needing to bail on something look when
this happens I called you two days ago
we spoke and I said listen I just think
you should put more effort into your
field right you know you're gonna go put
10 to 20 hours a week into somebody
else's [ __ ] career or driving or
loading or waitressing whatever [ __ ]
you're gonna do well if you put 10 more
harder hours into your job shit's gonna
happen you're gonna see shits gonna
happen right and that's what happened
you know things happen I mean I never
understood that
and I Adam and I hope you and I'm happy
you understood when I said to you what I
was saying no I understand I I hate it
I've only done it a couple times a night
there's nothing I it was so demeaning
doing it and it's not it's just a way
for the people and most of people were
cool but I'm the way people treated me I
was just like I'm not supposed to be
doing this and it's it's of course it's
about the money like I need the money
for the to pay taxes and I need the
money to live but I've been working with
you for almost four years I think and
even though my parents are supportive
him in the even though Paul is
supportive they don't really get it
like they my mom will call me and say oh
who else you doing a podcast with her or
she heard about other people who are
producing podcast you should go talk to
them and for me I don't know if it's
I put so much work into into what we've
been doing and I'm so invested in it and
yes we I I get to come and we hang out
we laugh and I get to have edible so I
understand why some people might not
understand it but I actually I this
sounds horrible but I'm gonna say it
before I left to do my taxes I actually
said a little prayer that I would be
able to oh uh Oh a little bit of amount
that would let me keep doing this
because yeah I would love to be a
millionaire it would be great but it's
been so important to me what we're doing
because it's it has my fingerprints on
it like I was have to getting my car
wash the other day and I saw these
people building a house and I could
never build a house ever but it was it's
it was cool I was a little bit high from
a podcast and I just watching them I'm
like that must be really cool to like
start building house finish and get to
see what you did and we when we started
we were doing we were using webcams and
I was popping them up with Lysol wipes
and we moved from my off my house to
another office we first started at your
house I was working ten hours a day and
then going to it so I I think a lot of
it is a little bit maybe I'm too
prideful maybe I do care too much about
it and I want to make it I want to see
this turn into I don't know a TV show or
someone sponsors us and gives us a
hundred grand a year each or I don't
know I don't know what is gonna come
from it but didn't I why did you I I was
thinking I was going to do over just to
make a little bit of money to pay off
what I owe but it's just and I could
have been very happy being an editor I
think I could have lived a very normal
life and and worked 60 hours a week or
whatever would have been but whenever we
have a great podcast
whenever somebody sends me an email now
it's it's so it it blows my mind and
it's just I was petrified of tax I was
nervous for a couple weeks I was going
through I'm trying to get all the
deductions I could and trust me now
listen bill is my first year only having
this so I really sympathize with anyone
who's doing their own stuff because they
they basically doubled my taxes with a
self-employment tax and I understand
that it's basically because you're not
paying into Social Security but everyone
always pushes the American dream on you
and the fact that they tax you more when
you're self-employed
he's just unbelievable to me so I was
petrified and ioio enough or a little
bit that I can still keep doing this I
don't have to go back and get an editing
job but I was petrified I was III don't
know how I would have called you and
said listen I can't do this anymore
that would that would have killed me
because you put so much faith into me
four years ago when I eat Facebook
message to you and I we started with
math flavored world videos and I would
edit them on the weekends and you give
me a hundred bucks a week when I knew
nothing I was building furniture a my
other job when I supposed to be an
assistant and you put so much faith in
and you've I don't want anyone to write
to you mil ago why are you paying me
more you're paying me more than most
podcast producers probably get paid so
it's not it's not that it's never about
the amount of money it's about loving
way yeah I think yeah it's that and then
who you're working like you're quick
it's funny brain brought up Greg
Fitzsimmons we you did his podcast a
year or so ago and I went with you and
he said what's the hardest part about
working with Joey and I I think about it
every now and then
you're not an easy person to work for in
many ways he you you want things faster
than sometimes they
you're you you never take a vacation
there's never a week off from the
podcast really but I've worked so many
jobs where bosses are are mean or bad
people or they don't they don't want to
want anyone else's input and this is
your podcast this is the I got very
lucky and you're well-known and and this
is your podcast but you never you never
make me feel like that you never you
never say it
sometimes you'll make fun of some of my
ideas but usually you're very open to it
and it's been it was gonna it was
killing me that was I think the part
that was killing me that I would have to
make that phone call say let's not to go
back to editing and I'll train somebody
else or I don't know what it would have
been but I'm glad that's not gonna be
the case first off I your handprint is
on this podcast while the people love
the podcast I was being together that's
that's the whole thing I'm blown away by
taxes too and I told you like a year ago
what I paid in taxes like home from the
podcast now they have a 10% city tax
mm-hmm for businesses for smaller
businesses it's like they come out here
for more [ __ ] direction and I think
that there's something here I listened
for years I was chasing not the American
Dream I was chasing a dream I was
chasing that I was going to do something
and bump into money right we all think
when we young bump into money we agreed
to this salary that we've taken a job we
go to that job every day and then six
months until no matter what job we have
no matter what we're paying us you
always gonna go [ __ ] I need to make more
that's just
that's what we're about you know and
you're working for somebody they have
whatever the [ __ ] they call it they pay
you uh and then you want more everybody
want some women you're like maybe how
bump it's like when you owe a lot of
money on your credit cards yeah and
you're like I gotta do something this
I've never seen myself gonna get away
from this like I'm never gonna get out
of this [ __ ] hole you know and you're
always thinking to bump into that
[ __ ] envelope you know I never
thought that I thought that's why I was
about 31 or 32 and then it got replaced
by something called hard work you know
we we [ __ ] party too much we live in
a society of people that they want to do
everything and then when things don't go
their way they want to cry well that
means you can't do everything right and
that was my that was my biggest problem
when I was in my 20s I wanted to do
everything but you can you know you pick
up two tabs that's 300 bucks you're only
getting 15 an hour or 12 an hour or 18
now or 20 an hour you're still getting
on our weight and you you go to a
restaurant
it's [ __ ] 150 or whatever with your
friends you know when you go to Vegas
it's [ __ ] cost money when you go to
all these places as a young man it costs
money and I would always try to catch up
with people I was always catching up huh
I'll put this next week I'll pay the
rent you're never gonna [ __ ] pay the
records next week something else is
gonna come up on Friday all right you
got the wrong [ __ ] friends you know
you gotta get friends that stay in at
night or whatever the [ __ ] it is when I
got into comedy it's funny I always tell
people this June is really gonna be 20
years of my comedy career I really
started in July of 91 but I decided it
took me four years to really attack
stand-up family do you know wildly
because of those years I was even though
I was doing shitty jobs and song cars
and I had to prepare myself for the
journey this was not gonna be an easy
journey and that's what people always
misinterpret that there's gonna be an
easy journey at first thought we live in
a place where everybody wants to go on
vacation three we see you and not just
[ __ ] the vacation cuz nobody just
wants to take a week off and plant
tomatoes oh no they got to go somewhere
exquisite and really [ __ ] themselves up
cuz it [ __ ] you head up after late for
days cuz
I live here could I do these things then
you have to go back to [ __ ] reality
to pay for that [ __ ] vacation right
so I'm not one to take a [ __ ]
vacation I believe that there's work
there's something I could be doing every
day that's my belief that's how I was
raised
that's what I've seen and thirty years
of being in a job market that people
work five days a week and uh well yeah
it's gonna be a hard [ __ ] life
brother unless you're making [ __ ]
$90,000 an hour right
you know for me to be at the level of
where I want my standup to be where we
want the podcast to be it takes effort
it takes work I gotta get up in the
morning and then taking notes and think
of things and music so it takes a lot
more work with this podcast we generate
some money from sponsors I caught it
with you 50% you know as close as I can
without paying that without paying the
bills and me losing money right and this
for me has been also a learning
experience I mean I don't wanna [ __ ]
quit doing a podcast but in my world you
know I don't know I just like
sacrificing I've always liked
sacrificing people always tell y'all
they went we party we went hand until we
started telling you how they're behind
on their credit card well you also went
there for [ __ ] two weeks guy you know
so there's so many [ __ ] variables of
living
it's just what we want to do I've always
believed and I said to you I said listen
there's so much more we could be doing
with this broadcast well it's not that
we've gotten lazy is that we've gotten
busy you know we're trying to put the
podcast up on roku now we're trying to
I'm trying to put together respect I
mean there's so many [ __ ] things that
you know like I was telling him for
years I was my own agent I knew it was
movies were making a movie it guy I
attacked that [ __ ] movie I don't have
the time to be my own agent no more
right I just don't you know I appreciate
you sticking this out and I know that
things are gonna change here you know
and then you have some thoughts in your
mind I mean you've got your t-shirts you
got your own blog you got your own
little things going on and they're only
gonna get better the way this podcast
got better all right but you got to
stick to it you can't have two bad weeks
and go I don't want to do it no more
everybody has two bad weeks we went
through a dry spell with the podcast a
year and a half ago or one number you
know and because I was putting attention
to the road
I wasn't putting attention to this I was
having too much [ __ ] road work and
not enough of this this is our bread and
butter I love doing this well I really
enjoyed doing the [ __ ] this you know
I love coming in Ian don't appeal but
I'm happy that you had that belief that
you believed in yourself to stay here
and come back let me tell you something
me and I don't know who the [ __ ] you're
kidding and I'm gonna tell you some
right now when you were editing you were
not a happy person no no you were not a
happy person I was there were some jobs
that would happen those jobs suck right
that overnight [ __ ] isn't better than
assistant you know in the even John bud
who's the brown belt over a v-max we've
had thousands of conversations about you
and he's told me a thousand times that
job your friend has an assistant editor
those jobs suck he's told me a thousand
times it's ready to get a higher job
like how to do it he was telling me for
you to go to his studio over you I just
you have to talk to him yourself I can't
I don't know the editing business so I
can't I would love for you to get a day
job if you get a day job we can still do
this at night you know if you wanna I'm
with you whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do you know but I don't want you to go
get a job and you're not gonna enjoy
it's the law of diminishing returns
the problem is with editing is I would I
was about three years into assistant
editing so on a very on a average scale
I was probably two to three maybe four
years away from editing being an editor
and the problem is is yes on paper if I
work nine to five we could do this every
night at 8:00 and that would be cool one
of the reasons I I decided to leave
editing was and you know this from
working in TV and movies there's no set
schedule and I understand why the
producers think that their thing is the
most important thing
because it's their name and and they're
the EPS and I understand that but if I
wanted to get an editing job right now
an assistant editing job which I'd be
doing it probably be from 10 to 7 and
then there'd be nights where I have to
be there until 8:30 or 9:00 and I could
there's no there's no job in editing
that I could do really and still do this
the way we're doing it and I well the
dry spot we went through about a year
and a half ago I was still working
nights or another job and I can see I
see myself doing better since then so if
like like I tell everyone who asks if it
got to the point where I'd be homeless
yeah I would I would get an editing job
and my I'm not gonna be stupid about it
but I'm okay not not having the nicest
apartment or not not not giving up some
things hoping that this will work out
and all I want you to do for a job what
does she expect from you as a job I mean
obviously you guys are getting more
serious you guys want to get married
she's been very cool she would never
want me to be unemployed not making any
money and I think if I were to propose
she would want something a little bit
more stable but she understands what I'm
doing and and she's been pretty cool
about it I think when we first started
dating I was making more money because I
was still doing TV so she seemed like I
did not a good client but I haven't been
able to do as many things as as before
which is fine I think it's mostly my
parents who and then they're always very
supportive they always ask about in
they're very supportive of it but they
want they saw how much money I was
making before and and they don't want me
to to have to think they want me to
worry about money and they know that
editing is even though it's not super
secure because you go from show to show
there's a guaranteed paycheck
they take taxes out and it's more of a
regular life so I see where they're
coming from so what does for you to
propose the pall of what would Paul to
say to you you have to go back and get a
day job a job I don't know if she'd say
that so you what would you do you go
back and work 10 the [ __ ] seven so
then what would she see you right and
that's that's what I do tell us
sometimes when I give like we had a
podcast on Friday and I couldn't see
until later I if I was working a regular
job I wouldn't have that sometimes we go
away on a Thursday night like if you're
gone sometimes we'll go away to like San
Diego or something so that wouldn't be
possible I don't think she would say I
have to go get another job I think if in
two or three years when will probably be
what's happening cuz I'm not gonna do
until after she graduates I think she
might ask me about it well which I
understand I mean you have a college
degree one of the things that can you do
what other things would you like to do
what are you interested in doing this I
love this
and I've always liked editing and I was
I was pretty good at it
and I was I was lucky enough to work on
some pretty good shows but you're right
when I want it when I said I would have
been happy that's not exactly true I
think me and maybe it's just I mean
you're gonna work ten to seven and
you're not gonna make much more money
than when I'm paying
I think the seminar you got to drive the
[ __ ] Santa Monica and you got to stay
up all life and look like the [ __ ]
Wolfman right I mean you weren't making
extrude with me more not at all not at
any [ __ ] ballpark and you were
working ten to [ __ ] seven right you
were putting together blocks and [ __ ]
houses and what the [ __ ] they told you
the sweeping [ __ ] right so in a way it
wasn't really assistant anything it was
more like you do everything well then
well that was I when I first started
wouldn't look towards the end right
couple of jobs that was I got was my
last job I was the lead assistant and it
all goes in charge of a couple other
senators and yeah I I was I think after
taxes I was making nine hundred a week
something someone like that so that's a
comfortable life
but I was not happy like I had something
like they would call me in at night over
the weekend because the producer [ __ ]
something I decided that I had to be
there so when you say I have a college
degree and what else could I do or do I
want to do I want that degree with that
degree but the degree in the gray have
is in digital post-production so that
all I can do is editing I could probably
get an insurance job or another kind of
office job insurance yeah I don't know
like a regular office job and I could
look at my job would you window I don't
want to do any other job I mean I've
gotten to me you and I got to meet all
the all the cool people we have and not
having to sit in traffic for three hours
a day is a big plus and that's when I
meant when I said that money isn't the
number one concern I would love more
money and that is a concern with me
being a bit being able to pay my bills
but I've who's had a happier year and a
half and I have I've gotten to do such
cool things I got to go to Austin with
you and some guy sent me an email last
week and I didn't get to read the whole
thing and he what he said was is that
I'm wasting my time doing this and and
then I'm on your coattails and I should
be making my own name and it that was
right before I was doing my taxes so it
kind of bummed me out but I thought
about it last night and part of its true
part of it is obviously if I was doing
this podcast with your clone but who
didn't have your name obviously the
numbers wouldn't be there what you like
but but you got to start somewhere
it's like what you're a podcast you know
I went on Rogen's podcast on one of the
other people's podcast any numbers are
huge and I went on the podcast and you
work and you work and you work and you
work now for a year and a half you've
done the podcast right and the big
difference is with those podcasts for me
is these guys don't work right their job
is over in here they walk in here 15
[ __ ] minutes late they don't prepare
anything
have nothing to talk about when they do
come in here they have a shitty [ __ ]
guest you know I work at this and that's
what people avoid when when people don't
want to do work they go okay that's it
I'm gonna do something else or something
like this and that's we've seen it with
we I pointed out to you I've said watch
this [ __ ] move this person is gonna
do you've seen it all right you've seen
it you've seen it from behind a [ __ ]
freak work is a foreign word for the
[ __ ] 60% of the people out here right
once they gotta do work the brakes go on
and they change [ __ ] whether it's a
script a book a movie [ __ ] anything
and you've seen it I've showed it to you
you bet how many intros that I make you
for people with podcasts I'm gonna have
worked out - this is work it's work at
any level you take your podcast right
now you first of all first off you have
never been on my coattail we have built
this together that's what these morons
during the stand from doing 100 hours
[ __ ] videos when I would give you the
camera on Mondays and you give it back
to me on Tuesdays we had nothing so if
we did this in four years what you could
do in two on your own the office is
available to you here nobody's in here
throughout the day right
you've got editing equipment in here
you've got computers you've got a
[ __ ] screen now that's what I was
saying to you this is when you go okay
what the [ __ ] you want to do for a
couple more yards takes a week I got to
be in a [ __ ] car and take orders and
work nights by myself with no air
conditioning
they [ __ ] leave you in the [ __ ]
garage at night that one there yeah
[ __ ] take a cab back and go back oh
yeah here you go from point A to point B
which is two miles right we [ __ ]
edibles the worst thing that happen as
soon as you go home you eat twenty-two
[ __ ] rice cakes but you're making
your own mark and you're starting
somewhere you know this all started for
me we're doing what opening for Joe
Rogan on the road okay but at the same
time what was I doing
I was building my own little niche every
time you guys that listen to the podcast
send me a picture of me and bass ketball
I was 1998 you sent me a thing of uh
Sopranos ah
MADtv that was 2003 spider-man - the
longest shard that was 2004 and [ __ ]
five when the podcast world come along
so no matter what I was doing with Joe
Rogan I was always doing my own thing
so people never confused me with Joe
Rogan that was very big to me that Joe
had been so kind and such a had such a
huge heart to take me on the road with
me and pay me he would take me and Ari
with him and pay us and take his
mistakes and you know first class plane
tickets you know Joe doesn't [ __ ] around
that's how I started you don't think I
was on his coattails and you bet your
ass I was but I really wasn't because I
was doing something for myself on my own
which is the most important [ __ ]
thing in this life I don't give a [ __ ]
if you're [ __ ] we all what a 60% of
our kids you grew up did they went to
work for their [ __ ] fathers that's
not being on somebody's go tell right
who the [ __ ] are you kiddin I work for
your father where you live in you living
at the house you ain't paying rent and
mom is still cooking for you you're on
that coattail what happens after four
years that you work for your father you
actually learned the [ __ ] trade and
then what happens then you put your own
spin on it your own artistic [ __ ] way
on it this things we do with this
podcast and I'm sure you don't [ __ ]
like Lee and I love that you don't
[ __ ] like it because that's how much
better your podcast is when you start
doing a podcast it is already you're
doing a lot better than these other
[ __ ] Bobo's you had in here with your
[ __ ] eight weeks and you're not a
[ __ ] comedian you're not even a
[ __ ] comedian I did a [ __ ] podcast
for a woman that was a 20 year comic and
she couldn't get the work ethic of what
this podcast is so I've told you a
thousand times in four years you're
gonna have the knowledge to take over
this town it's what you do it I love
what's his name Barry yeah I didn't like
what he said to you tonight cuz he tried
to do it in a you know whatever way and
half of these [ __ ] idiots listening I
don't believe that that you didn't have
career as a manager well guess what
you're gonna have more of a careers
imagine here's cuz you're a career
you're a manager dialed in 2015
half these [ __ ] people I talked it in
the day that walk around parading like
their big agents and managers don't have
the main ingredient they don't have the
get-go so always remember that you're on
nobody's coattail unless you're not
doing something if you were home fanning
your [ __ ] yes master and you're running
over here but that's not the case is
that the case with you or not no no we
set a time we goof I call you I tell you
my what my dilemmas are you solving for
me how many problems you solved for me
you ever think about that
how many problems you solve for me I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing here
I'll call you and say this is slipping
you go maybe maybe you should do it boom
and that's it you make little
adjustments so now you got to take these
adjustments and put them into your and
what the [ __ ] you're doing and that's
what people never understand you always
start on some of these coattail as as
horrible as that sounds yeah you don't
think I get it [ __ ] you Joey Joe Diaz
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] because of my
heart I know I did something on the side
I wrote my own jokes while I was working
with Joe Rogan I'm out I'll [ __ ] get
Joe Rogan on the phone right now how
many [ __ ] times have you people said
Joey you were supposed to be with Joe no
I'm doing my own [ __ ] thing because I
want Joe to give me that respect I
always wanted Joe to call me sometimes
for me to go hey Joe no I can't do that
we can come on shall we get no because I
always wanted Joe to know that I was
doing my own work right I'm doing my own
work brother I know what you're doing
I'm with you you know I got your back I
gotta take care of this and he would get
off the phone and he'd be mad for a week
but then in a week he call me indoor dog
I'm really proud of you got that movie
you got that sitcom or you got that
because you and I both know I got no
help I complain to you all the [ __ ]
time my agents you know there are
another [ __ ] planet if I don't do it
nobody [ __ ] does it right so a lot of
these people misconstrue what we're
doing here they think that I'm here
throwing bottles at your [ __ ] war on the
road and you sending me bro you want a
water what do I always say I'll get it
myself
you're my equal I never wanted you to
stink then you gotta [ __ ] get
anything or that's not the way it is you
don't think you do for me that I like
that you do it I don't like to do is you
gonna
- guess I don't know walk down those
stairs my knee [ __ ] hurt but besides
that I said you'll never be on my coat
elf you contribute to this you help this
you enhance this now you have to figure
out how to do this for yourself how to
take this then take what you've learned
together and add your own spin and
develop your podcast or take another
young comic and go ahead man I might
have an idea for you but I got a
condition if you [ __ ] quit before six
months I'll sue you for ten thousand
dollars and you make them sign that
contract and they have to be have a
certain time and they have to have the
same discipline you what I have had cuz
I've told you a thousand times at 26 I
would have canceled eight times already
I would have been [ __ ] coked up so
don't ever feel that just uh take what
you have in the knowledge you have and
go forward you never be on my coattails
you'll never be on nobody's throat there
that's why I always tell young comics
when you work with something on the road
I want you to make your own move so
every once in a while when you call him
you say home hey I'm busy this week I
can't [ __ ] do it with Tony Bennett
you
somebody Frankie hello what's up my
brother Joey what's going on how are you
buddy I'm good don't get I was vanilla
it was hot hi I was kind of like the
hotel was nice casino like and then the
rest of like Slumdog Millionaire and
awesome yeah how is the food in the
hotel it's all Americanized and I stuck
that stuck to this stuff I I'm going to
eat you know I was how's New Jersey
doing right now is it still [ __ ] cold
it's [ __ ] cold man when it won't go
away I won't go away well I think it
supposed to warm up next week a little
bit my buddy called me today it was Joey
it's still 29 degrees man a heck is
unreal so what's happening my brother I
wanted to get John for a long time you
know just talk about whatever you know
you're one of my all-time favorites and
after I haven't seen you sister cups
wants and fight and I gotta tell your
brother
un-fuckin'-believable unbelievable
Frankie I good you get better every time
you step in that [ __ ] Octagon man
every accent yeah you know that's what I
try to do before every fight just just
make sure I I could be myself the next
one and comes once there's no walk in
the park man I mean you just I'm gonna
call and Joe that night and going Joe
what I want for Christmas is Frankie egg
against the Irish man and I twittered it
and [ __ ] people got pissed off at me
[ __ ] but you know how we do it Frankie I
got we straight we go straight at that
[ __ ] lion that's right I'll get
there we're gonna get a good dog no no
and now you got you Raya Faber
next month yeah yeah may 16 oh [ __ ] back
in Manila uh you know he's a great guy
he's a great fighter I mean this is a
great fight for you I read somewhere
that for you this is like a championship
fight I mean all of them are all of them
wanna
what are you doing different for this
one yeah I just think stuff man you know
I mean I'm playing the top guys for a
long time I go in there I'm expecting
this was like the best uriah tourism
and more so I'd worry about myself I see
I caught up and we'll take the other guy
that actually maybe a little bit of
shame but now we just worry about what
we do when we go about my business no
it's uh you like I said I've been
watching your fights lately I watched
the the other night Jose Aldo was on the
main event at about 1:00 yeah yeah about
that and I tell you you know I talk a
lot of [ __ ] Frankie and the truth of the
matter is there's only one fight of a
place money on and that's you mom or me
and my wife went in there for the
hundredth show when you fought the kid
that retired we bet you and I don't bet
anybody because it's I love the sport I
didn't want to ruin it like football for
me like it's just every time i watch
football now is just I don't watch it no
more because I can't bend it so I want
that to happen to me with the UFC
because I really loved the whatever of
it and I know that I hurt a it's a
couple months ago
Connor was flying dennis siver and I was
watching UFC tonight and I can see you
were just doesn't come at me and if you
couldn't you want to jump through that
[ __ ] screen and fall of yourself I
mean I just know the jersey body
language that's the way it goes you know
and it's a business is for and I'm
learning that you know no it's like me
it's a business it's not about the
funniest guy this is a business it's
about who they can't see and who they
are but I'm looking forward to this year
I favor fight I'm looking forward to
whatever happens in July with those two
[ __ ] knuckleheads and then you get
the winner of that you know I mean yeah
obviously I gotta take care of business
with your ayat but uh when I go to hold
that Bell again it's all going away and
you're still training it and rent Enzo's
or you try me Jerry the end of the city
I go up there once a while you know it's
just tough tough ride man but uh you
know I will record Almeida man advantage
now from your place and toms river' is
it is that what you live in there yeah
- Henry that's where he's at Henry New
Jersey I don't even know what the [ __ ] I
mean of Jersey is
whoa no no no he's in a Carlos did not
he's in Robins little New Jersey it's
like kinda by trend area and how far is
that right it's really a 40 minute ride
for this I'm gonna ride I've never even
heard what that sound is that yeah it's
like it's on a weight so off 195 on a
way to trend now let me ask you this
this kid that I watched yesterday at the
Annie Bravo taught him and Gary told him
you know this guy yeah yeah yeah he came
to us he was he's in like he was in one
town away not diseased man oh my god you
know Frank I know a little bit of
jiu-jitsu I go twice a week you know I
got other things going on I go down to
he ghen you know and I'm a white belt I
like you know Kimora's and next jokes
and [ __ ] like that gear jokes I know
nothing I was telling leave let me tell
you something I never want to become a
blue belt cause I don't want people
[ __ ] with my feet and I don't want to
touch nobody off his [ __ ] feet it was
like a light walk seminar yesterday I
didn't know what was going on so it was
very high level for me the car to see
what was going on but there was some
great matches anyway but Gary's a
[ __ ] he and he's not scarce compete
against anybody you know he was always
hot in there anybody man he's impressive
to watch a couple weeks ago some people
with training whatever the city
somewhere and one of the guys ruled I've
come with Gary I just got a five guys
burger and I [ __ ] went off you're in
[ __ ] New York and you get a five guys
[ __ ] burger you can eat one of those
gamma burgers anyway but I'm gonna
sausage and peppers of [ __ ] I just yeah
dick Gary man he's a he's a stuntman all
right you know I'm gonna see he's talked
about me possibly getting better nice
well yeah yeah that was that was
tremendous just do you have any
questions for when we have Frankie yeah
hey Frankie my name is Leah produced the
show I don't know if you saw it or not
but this weekend there was a crazy call
in in Brazil where the ref called a
stoppage and the guy wasn't even close
to tapping I really if you don't want to
talk about it that's fine
but like you have said he is like the
only major sport
where the ref and like the rules are in
another organization like the NFL
pleases itself so it's kind of weird as
a fan of other sports to hear Dana White
like arguing for no contest why it like
why do you think the UFC doesn't have
its own rules and until refs and I don't
understand what mode would be stopping
them from that yeah I mean oh I'm the
reason I think they don't have no rules
people don't wanna thing like the UFC is
fixed and fights and UFC is telling the
judge you're the referee to do this and
do that that's why I think you know you
like to keep it as a third party but I
mean half these commissions and right
judges and referees and they may be any
sonken cuz I mean usually bad cake walls
and weekly you know have you ever had a
fight that ended with a call like that
because I must it much just killed a
fighter who loses and it must mess up
the guy who wins too much thinking maybe
he didn't really win yeah I've never
been a situation like that well that's
unfortunate man you know a lot of people
over here
you put a lot in tradition you know I
think that guy would rather been knocked
out then that happen to him I can't I
can't even imagine and Joey told I think
this was it was about Frankie right know
about going fighting in bars in New
Jersey is that was that him Joey no no
we were talking about the toughness of
the Jersey Shore
the same story I told you about that
time and Mister breakfast left the
bracket battle and my buddy fought the
guy and I always say that you know the
Jersey Shore gets [ __ ] [ __ ] on by
these [ __ ] like guys like my friends
that will go down the shore on the
weekends and bark where the [ __ ] they
want to and have barbecues and
double-park and make noise and then your
family comes over and knocks on the door
that the [ __ ] people rented to us and
then I say something to your parents and
you got a cut you know there was always
drama
I remember going down and I'm a [ __ ]
Jack I never great drama like that in
front of somebody's house you say always
go somebody's [ __ ] lives next door to
these people and they kind of put up
with all this [ __ ] people having parties
and then I got into I saw with the
fistfights and I'm like you know what it
just makes sense that these guys down on
the shore
have to be [ __ ] tough because they
put up with so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then as I got older you know we play
football against brick township and you
play play football against these short
teams and these [ __ ] guys you gotta
hit him to [ __ ] knock him down and I
knew this for years and then you come
along and then you come along and I'm
trying to explain the people listen man
watch this guy because I know these
little [ __ ] guys they're a little
smaller they're deceiving and they
bounce around but they'll [ __ ] you up
don't [ __ ] you up like what you do you
just [ __ ] people up there getting
transferred your little Bob and your
little weave which is at the top of its
[ __ ] game I was at home trying to
punch it I couldn't [ __ ] punch it
that's how much you're bobbing and
weaving against what's-his-name but it's
it's the new jersey Shore's always meant
something like even wrestlers they
always have great wrestlers down there
you know it's cold down there all
[ __ ] winter they gotta stay in the
basketball teams have always been great
and it's like they have this heart that
people just you know when you fought uh
what's the [ __ ] guy's name out of
Vegas that was your team coat or that
time I tell people you gotta hit Frankie
with a [ __ ] sink and then pray you
don't get up you don't get up because
it's like a toughness they show up
continue you know yeah and I definitely
I definitely need some subscribes
overseas out over the bridge and
anaconda in nature but growing up down
here you know got the guys well north
come and China so I step on your turf
it's [ __ ] crazy and they do it every
week and after a while I know it's got
to be
I saw a fistfight remember the body in
the water slide and Seaside Heights yeah
yeah that you used to put you use it
like you went with your t-shirt off but
if you're paid an extra ten bucks they
give you like a body suit and you did
like thirty miles an hour even faster I
saw yeah the rainbow rainbow rapids and
rainbow rapids it's not there no more
they can't no no they got some different
now yeah rainbow ravaged I saw Swiss
right there Frank yet the kid got hit
with a bottle he still kept coming it
was like walking [ __ ] dead I've seen
some [ __ ] down the jury I think for
violence san francisco's number one of
the jersey shore one time what's the one
up from la Villette or it's nice people
and stuff poorly
or Lea lavallette its next deceased yeah
la Villette la Villette marry next to
each other yeah I saw a fist fight down
there that must have took him it was
like 25 minutes
you know I'm Batman you see a fighter it
takes two [ __ ] seconds pam pam pam
these guys kept coming each other after
the shirts were ripped and they stopped
and drank water
they kept [ __ ] fight again around
their round they had rounds this is a
street fight but they're relentless and
that's and that's you know and listen
man that stop that's why I think people
love about you that's why you're a fan
[ __ ] favor and that's what I wanted
you to just call in so I could tell you
that I love you to death Frankie I
appreciate him and I appreciate you love
me I gotta represent Jersey man wait I
know you're in a nice weather now but
you know I can't forget your oh listen
man I miss Jersey Jersey is Who I am
Frank yeah good would you [ __ ] look
at me man I got none but Jersey I am a
lie yeah I can tell oh my god what I
came for you know and people and the
Italians love me because they're all
about mama so when my mama died they
[ __ ] took me in you know they just
tied in and you got the Irish the
Italian a couple of Germans a couple
Jews you put that all together there's
one there's always one black kid we
always have hey guys the token black I
got ya the token black guy and they all
mix up hey what are you coming back out
here do UFC tonight I don't know it's
almost like you know I'm just a yeah
stay at it until uh from May 16th and I
definitely a but I'll be out there do
your season I felt like that when you
come on man I like you to see it maybe
come on and talk to us I know it's late
over there in Jersey I don't want to
take yeah that's gonna be great man yeah
I just wanted to be the call and let you
know I love you with your for you here
at the church we got you that's it man
you're one of us
I appreciate it man you guys are the
best man you're funny and [ __ ] man so uh
it's a pleasure being on show hey you
two and I'll watch you I'll see you
somewhere I'll be in Vegas Memorial Day
weekend hopefully you'll be out there
[ __ ] around
yeah we'll be dead with celebration all
right I love you Frankie thank you very
much for taking the time I'd rather be
giving I'll see you at 16 knock them
dead brother god
what's up Lisa I yeah not much buddy how
you feeling you're still a little high
I'm brain I would give some shoutouts as
[ __ ] my main man Quinn from Ottawa
Alex Henriques happy birthday
Lewis Robertson been he took my dad Mike
Wilson Sean Barrett Phillip Craig and
chunk Kennedy I love you [ __ ]
you know did you see the video of Bruce
Lee cuz Harris doing a bare-knuckle
fight and like a portable no I didn't
see that oh my god let me pull it out is
he still in the UFC I'd said he was I
didn't a another fight but this was a
few years before the UFC let me pull it
up it's a terrible uh I want to thank
some of the people that uh most of the
people that watched the how he should
fear show on Comedy Central Yemen I got
a bunch of great remarks from you people
and great feedback you know this is not
happening show yeah I don't know what
the numbers were whatever but I gotta
tell you something man it was [ __ ]
great getting that story off my chest
I hate watching myself I've always been
don't worry about it don't worry about I
got a big I've always been a big against
watching myself I [ __ ] hate Italy I
hate you know Lee always stays on me and
D'Agostino but you don't tape your set
Joey you should have tape what you said
I [ __ ] hate listening to myself I hate
that whole thing so I'm at the Comedy
Store Thursday I'm at uh somewhere first
and then I go to the comedy store think
it wasn't till a factory I think it was
at the Laugh Factory yes I was at the
Laugh Factory and I go up to the
comments but I do my set and I get in my
car and I go home and as I [ __ ]
walked in the door my wife was taping
Comedy Central and oh nine thirty she
went to bed so Comedy Central had been
left on so basically I walk in put go on
the bathroom take a pee I was gotta pee
when I walk in I washed my hands I go
get some coffee when I walk out always
bringing me up so I watched it
and I forgot what I said as I usually
[ __ ] do you know so Ryder was this
lady who just was a dear friend of my
mother's man and she heard my mother
which is super tightly they would talk
for [ __ ] hours at least you know even
when you're 30 you know when I was a kid
there was only one phone in the house
right you know so there was times I
wanted or sometimes I would and I don't
I'm lying to you guys I had a phone in
my room but my own phone number but
there was times I wanted to make another
call it was the call Whaley so I would
go in the kitchen and my mom would be
I'm gonna fall my [ __ ] is me and why
they were trying to put a Bennett so I
would have to call my bookie from the
other thing and then tell whitey on the
phone the line is six and a half that's
hysterical yeah we were kids you know we
didn't [ __ ] know so she would always
be on the phone with you right ASA get
pissed off mom get off the [ __ ] phone
oh I love can you talk to somebody for
it was always that attitude you know
this lady [ __ ] came through man she
just was my mother's dear friend and
they used to laugh at night and the last
six months of my mom's life it was
really sad she was really sad about
losing my up my stepfather and the bar
and all this [ __ ] she was worried about
her future and how she's gonna make a
living and the right I made it all
better
well he's right it would just come to
the hospital come to the house and just
make it all better my mom had a surgery
about a month and a half before she died
on her stomach something was bothering
like falesha Crohn's or whatever okay so
something was bothering her so she got
surgery so uh I was a writer was there
so writer was just always around you
know and it was funny she had an
apartment in Spanish Harlem but she
lived a long time she had that much
money so right had made millions from
what I heard I heard she was sending a
bunch of light a cube every month oh and
she was sending money in a bank you know
she had a drug operation over a bodega
on 113th Street and she had security on
the street she had security of a [ __ ]
hallway so right it was a badass [ __ ]
you know she had the drug
she had the drug trade down she had I
think she had another apartment in the
area
what she would do is she get there like
a tent and she prepped the drugs for the
day and then sell drugs to like four
then she'd get so [ __ ] up she'd taken
that for two or three hours and then
she'd come back and work from seventh
only to in the morning
selling coke and little bags of heroin
you know and I would go over there as a
kid and I'd make believe I didn't know
what she was doing but I know what the
[ __ ] she was doing I think the greatest
thing about the story and I watched it
on TV and then I watch it on YouTube
tell me if I'm wrong but I don't think
you really work this out
did you oh did you I know you I know you
planned it but I'll you never did it on
stage no I can't do it on stage who the
[ __ ] would tolerate that I think a lot
of people when they were watching at me
me included my moment when you get sort
of caught up and yes it was if I was
gonna make a silly gosh and
advertisement about that show to get
that job picked up like that moment is
I'm assuming what Ari wants because
there's no one I know who could watch
that and not get choked up but then
right after you do the line about erotic
giving your mom coke in the casket and
the entire room explodes because like
the camera it's like you can see
yourself about to cry and like the whole
audience is just silent the thing I the
reason I could tell is a good story
the bartenders were watching if you look
in the back of the video the bartenders
at the strip club were leaning on the
bar just watching and it was it was like
it was amazing the scene how was in the
moment I had to be in the moment because
I never told that story publicly
nevermind I never told my wife this this
is something I lived with for 20 [ __ ]
years that I I didn't do right by this
woman I had not done right by her after
everything she did for me you have no
idea how many nights like I said I would
just make up a [ __ ] story
I got 11 o'clock at night I'd be with
you [ __ ] up with no money and I call
her up if you got a phone bro let me go
through you know
let me call Leo I'll call up she'd be
there she'd go what he don't none man
listen I just got a call I gotta go to
the University of mission to the school
there's no [ __ ] universe in Michigan
there was not school she would go what
do you need it's three four hundred can
you get over here right now I'm gonna be
in front of that I'll be there [ __ ]
20 minutes I get over that I get 300 400
I said listen let me get a gram of cokes
I could sell my friend my car there was
no [ __ ] friend in the car it was my
firm ation give me the gram and go keep
the hundred dollars and I [ __ ] its North
Dakota you have no idea you have no idea
how bad I feel about this and towards
the end was horrible was just a kid I
didn't know I was just a kid what do you
think because you've told stories where
you beat other drug dealers and you
don't feel you've said you don't feel
bad about it cuz they're drug dealers
what do you think it is about her that I
didn't beat her for money I beat her
because she loved she really loved me
you have no idea she loved me but she
loved my mother she didn't call me Coco
and she didn't call me Joey she'd call
me casita what's that mean of his little
thing the only other thing that was
little in her life was her Chihuahua
that was casita casita means like this
little thing like the little Sita this
little thing so that's what she used to
call me I mean she used to babysit me
when I came from Cuba
she used to my mom used to go I used to
leave you with her and it was horrible
because she would get tanked and let you
do whatever he would let you like if you
wanted a piece of chicken she'd go buy
your 20 pieces of chicken if you want a
candy she took in boy you candy it was
just wasn't healthy so I couldn't leave
it with you anymore
she loved me man she loved me she
watched me grow in front of her eyes she
wants to become a man then she helped me
become a man you know but then it's like
anything else the drugs you know
somebody wrote me today and I told him
what addiction is addiction means
[ __ ] your friends and their loved
ones you know mentally physically
spiritually that's what you do you weigh
on your friends every time you see melee
as much as you love me you know I'm
gonna hang you up for 50 bucks or a ride
or you know and you like doing coke too
but eventually you like Joey that's it
you know I don't mind taking a ride with
you and [ __ ] around we're doing a
bumper
but that's [ __ ] it and as I was
watching me tell the story because it
sucked me into you know it sucked me and
just I was very proud I was very proud
that I kept her alive I kept her ride
alive in my heart every time I make a
move I always think of Jesus Christ you
know I I wish she was alive to see me
doing this to see me not doing coke
could not be in the CVS and not being a
bad person I wish she would have got the
same and I know that she's somewhere
watching me of my mother right now she
passed I got the news when I went to
Miami my my godmother of his friends
with her niece mm-hmm but she didn't
really know what had happened she just
thought I'd disappeared the same way she
disappeared she lived three years after
that I just had no contact with her you
know and I can't lie to you when I went
over it when I went back to New York in
91 I went over into the city and I
walked around and I asked questions even
six years later I still it bothered me
not making it right with her that's what
it was
I feel my telling the story and letting
everybody know what I did how I acted I
made it right she was a funny lady man
she was a ballsy [ __ ] lady man her my
mother were two women that I have the
utmost respect for because of the the
Valor the balls they showed you know
they really did she was a woman selling
drugs in the 70s in Harlem with no
husband she didn't want a husband she
didn't want a man around there she
didn't want nobody around she had
nothing it was just her and that [ __ ]
Chihuahua and a gun in her purse she had
me two or three guns on an autopsy
she always [ __ ] pieces on her alpha
she always had one in her underwear one
in her purse
and one in her bra like a 22 like a
little one at its with huge she put it
right over here sometimes the barrel not
the barrel but the thing of the handle
stuck out so she would put it right over
here so she would pull it out here when
you went to buy drugs he was just it was
a different time it was a you know and
she loved Bailey she really [ __ ]
loved me which is something that Israel
like a friend of your parents
loves you there weren't sisters they
weren't they had no blood between them
there would dear friends and it taught
me how to be a friend it taught me what
you your friend you know people always I
don't have no you know the show friends
ruined America
and I will to get on into that war that
night on stage but I only have 15 misses
when I rolled out that was parlor write
up the show friends ruined America
because let everybody think that they
have to go with eight people life is too
complicated to have any [ __ ] fission
I have to appease wall of them to be
nice to all I'm going to get along right
that's why I said you know when you have
a grammar school friend you have two or
three [ __ ] friends you could take
over everything
because whatever you need I can call you
legally I got this problem it's not
money it's I'm getting a job as an
editor and I'm gonna do another podcast
but I can't you know I'm saying that's
what friends do they take care of each
other's mental you know dilemmas right
they ease the mental dilemmas when you
call me with the tax thing I talk to you
and I I busted your balls about going to
jail you know a little bit for like
three days you call me alright I got a
new deal for you you only do seven years
but then you go to a halfway house yeah
but I that's what friends do people
misinterpret they want to have all these
friends and have these bodies and have
all these people I would you want to do
that I don't wanna [ __ ] eighty
friends I just need three [ __ ]
to make it work and they did and the
fact that she came every week wait I
can't do [ __ ] every [ __ ] Sunday I
would be there at 1:00 I would have to
get a ride to all those bar and grill
I'm 30th the New York Avenue I'd walk in
she'd have it would be her another lady
if two other ladies and two guys I
should take a cab from New York with
everybody and the bar would be hopping
people would go there to meet her like
my mom's friends and she'd be buying
drinks giving our bumps there was a
hotdog place in front of itlet's a bread
hotdog then we'd be out there even at
those then we call a cab or she keep the
cab from New York and get him in come on
get out of the car come inside drink
with the [ __ ] cab driver don't we
take a ride down to the cemetery
and I do our thing that was a half hour
she'd give me cash she talked to me
about last week what I was going to do
whatever and then she leave me there cuz
I lived right around the corner from
Weehawken cemetery and then she'd go
right back to Long Island or sometimes
she'd go back to Harlem close out the
night and then go back to Long Island
she did that every weekend for somebody
who was no blood Tara that's loyalty
that's friendship
that's that's something that's unheard
of today you know I see us I saw Sun I
talked about Marilyn and I spoke about
to Jeff Valdez [ __ ] thing how I
[ __ ] almost killed him but I finally
got that guy's business [ __ ] face no
no I wanted to talk to you about that
that was my favorite part of your story
because you could have ended it at the Z
thing about that you weren't able to to
be there for her that could have been
the end of your story but you took it
and you brought it back around the other
way which I haven't said storytelling he
is really big right now and I don't see
a lot of people doing that so I for that
part like people with people have been
tweeting me because apparently I laugh
at a certain point no one else does my
favorite part of any performance you
ever have is the thing that I don't
think anyone else notices only a couple
people notice or stuff that makes you
laugh onstage because everyone else is
hearing the jokes for the first time so
but you doing that extra bit about
Marilyn was so cool you you thought
about this story you must have thought
about the story for a long time well I
didn't think I thought about the
friendship story and let's be honest it
let's be [ __ ] totally alastair I I
thought I liked the man with the the
we'll have a story yeah and then I heard
for a few months I've been hearing
through friends that a couple people
said that they were they couldn't work
with me because of what I had done
probably store that night into Jeff a
lot of people said you know what don't
work with him because the whole
town knows about that I got to do
business with and Hollywood is a place
this area here I don't know if society I
don't know what's going on out there I
know this place here we live in a place
where you can't tell somebody they're
doing something wrong these Hollywood
people these directors and these writers
and whatever you can't say to them hey
man don't talk to me that way
you know you've worked the [ __ ] up
bosses and said I'm only talk to you
certainly like do me a favor don't talk
to me that way
most people would go home man and then
come back and I said say me I'm very
sorry for talking to you that way you're
absolutely right I won't desire you
don't deserve that here in Hollywood
people get pissed off if you call them
out right Jeff had been running people
amok for years he had been the scumbag
to people for years primarily is old
people there's all Mexican Latin friends
he was being the scum back then he had
his favorites but everybody else he was
a [ __ ] [ __ ] too and I had noticed
it he was a [ __ ] to me he did
something to me that hurt me [ __ ]
tragically but it made me a better stand
up what do you do he he wanted me to
showcase the Sun he made me showcase for
a festival like four or five times clean
and then he told me I didn't get the
festival and then he added a dirty show
to really rub salt I [ __ ] won't
I had just gotten to Hollywood I wasn't
prepared for that I would I still live
life how men live life when I tell you
i'ma do something I do it I got here and
these aren't men these are all a bunch
of [ __ ] nomads that have no soul so
they don't get they don't they're not
accountable for their words and
accountable for their actions
right they always blame it on somebody I
wasn't me it was the producer it was you
you [ __ ] it was you you
[ __ ] so when he did that to me
after that I got numb towards him I
didn't really because I knew I wanted to
always smack him Marylyn kept [ __ ]
around and kept getting burnt by him now
he kept [ __ ] around with him and
Marilyn needed the money so Marilyn
would dick around with the dollars and
cents I would I just said I'm gonna
avoid that [ __ ] guy but I'm never
gonna forget what he did tonight Marilyn
the weekend Marilyn died is the truth I
hadn't been I had snorted coke when I
got the news that Marilyn died I haven't
been clean for four days by the time
they did the way
clean a week I was clean seven days by
the time I went down there I was furious
when I seen him down there I went off I
threatened them from the stage you know
I told him hey get the [ __ ] out of here
I'm gonna [ __ ] stab you even though
they left and I was furious I never
thought about it that way when I found
out that people were mad at me
for sticking up for a friend of mine
whether it was awake or whatever the
[ __ ] it was it hurt my feelings because
I wanted them to know the story where it
came from that's why that story wouldn't
have been the whole story if I wasn't
told the way story right if I want to
just went up there and told the story
about Marilyn it wouldn't assault had to
compare I had to compare it to what made
me like me beaten the coke for a week
was huge yeah but me sticking up for
[ __ ] Marilyn that night was even
bigger in my world you know why because
it taught me that over the years the
addiction that hidden my manhood and it
did don't work don't get me wrong I was
still an [ __ ] and I still stuck up
for myself I just stuck up for my it was
a it was a personal stick up for myself
I would stick up for myself against the
industry and when I did that it sent me
[ __ ] freely it made me a better
[ __ ] man
I remember the drive home going holy
[ __ ] I haven't been this person in 30
[ __ ] years what happened to this
person what happened to this person I
fought what he believed for that
leave you called me when I was a kid
said you're a problem with a
[ __ ] I said get in the car we're
gonna be what ain't mother [ __ ] even
though I knew I was gonna lose I still
want because we went there and stuck up
for ourselves and sometimes bro they
could be eight people on the corner they
see you stick when eight guys are
standing on a corner on a six guys a
five guys and two guys pull up in the
car one guys been abused the other guy
shows up these five guys are thinking
what's this [ __ ] guy thinking but
he's stepping up to us from what my
himself he's got something we don't know
about so sometimes doing that levels off
to play a field that people's minds he's
got something he may have a [ __ ] gun
for a long time when I was in LA I stuck
up for myself as a human
think of myself as a comedian and after
that night with Jeff I stuck up for
Marilyn and myself and I got that car
the drive home
no matter how bad I want this I'm I
cried on the drive home because I had
bad those feelings don't feel as they
come out oh my god now it's Coco again
this is Coco Diaz this is not Joey beers
no more some ha ha ha ha ha guys you
guys for years so Joey Diaz now the
people you see is Coco Diaz this is how
I was raised these are my thoughts this
is what my beliefs were at a young age
so by me sticking up for him bro and
meant the world to me let's say it's
true that some people more with you
because of what you did does any part of
you regret it that well I don't give a
[ __ ] because Davin eliminates the
middleman I don't have to do business
with them we don't have the same beliefs
they look at the sign they could say hey
man it wasn't classy there was a write
up two days later the LA Times and I
still have at the house hidden somewhere
Terry's got it in a book about what he's
in about everything that happened that
just wait somebody if there was a writer
there from the LA Times that covered the
wake and he put Jeff's name in and Jeff
tried to fight the LA Times they told to
[ __ ] off that they we're gonna check the
allegations and they checked them and
they said yeah the kids right [ __ ] off
and he got super pissed so that's what
really I hit him where it [ __ ] hurt
like I really got him they came out of
the news and everything came out the
only times that front [ __ ] page me on
a stage point they had a [ __ ] week
yeah picture oh yeah they got a picture
of it all I have to look for yeah yeah
crazy all you should bring it in so
that's what it was it was more about me
becoming me but after I did it then I
remember I was a riot at the wake
choking yeah mister whatever his name
was he was a good dude bro that dude
that ran to for you know ball in Jersey
I battled whatever his name was he was a
good Cuban dude and to write a [ __ ]
joke them because they put the wrong
dress out that's what got me choked up
once I started saying that story because
I haven't thought about it it was a
thought not a reality coming out of your
mind but the wrong dress on my mother
you should have seen this woman
that's what's that you are really that's
not what set me off that's what sets a
right off well no no but I'm saying
that's what maybe you get more
yeah just saying it that night saying
that hole reliving it like I was there I
was at that wake again
I still remember going outside and
coming back in it was a Sunday night
maybe 12:30 I still remember that Lee
and smelled the formaldehyde like that
that scent never got out of my nose and
just sitting in the back and walking him
while the rider was petting her I said
I'll never forget that memory that that
memory is etched by Sturm was a writer
had the brown dress on it was just the
most times she was kneeling down and she
was just touching her hair and she was
touching her cheek and she was just
telling everybody you know and I said it
wrong with the thing what she was saying
that her world wouldn't be the same like
my world's gonna be completely
differently and then we're gonna get to
talk to you never date them when they
were gonna giggle about this I'm giggle
about the men so talking about this guys
[ __ ] ugly [ __ ] you know what she was
saying all these things to her and I was
remembering my mom laughing like I would
and I just broke that and then she just
said I'm gonna take care of your son and
I came over we all hugged you know I
hugged does arrived and kissed her and
she was crying that was great but I
could see how much it hurt her that
night and then I went away for a corner
and I did my finger maybe an hour later
I was sitting there by myself away just
by myself
it had to be maybe they were gonna bury
her I was gonna go home about 6:00 take
a shower and put a suit on and come back
in about an hour later I don't know
where the [ __ ] a writer was I just
lost it I just lost it
I [ __ ] lost it I I couldn't believe
she was gone that that bite was you know
you go through all the motions all
weekend you think he gonna do okay right
there I lost it and that was I never
lost again the next day at when they
threw dirt on her I lost her a little
bit the next day's a Ryan I went to the
city where they buried my mom she went
to the city after we went we all wait so
right yeah that she went to the city she
got half of stuff she trusted her drug
business with some minions and she
came and stayed with me until
Thanksgiving so I would be okay
Thanksgiving was when I moved with the
Bender's Thanksgiving Day and then she
went back to New York to resume so for
three weeks she stayed with me at full
awake after the funeral just me and her
she would cook for me she'd make me
breakfast
she washed my clothes she makes sure I
had money every day that's what she did
lived in my mother's house with me you
have no idea this has never said that
before no no no this is something that
people would never understand this is
why would you think you have a good
friend that you think you're a good
friend
you have to reek Walla fie if you really
do you have no [ __ ] idea she stayed
with me I still wonder the last night I
took acid well the last night she was
staying with me I took acid and that was
why I came home with the father The Blob
was out okay and I was giggling by
myself and she came out of the room
saying what are you doing hey you okay
you want something I was like no and
then I'm walking over and getting his
girl walking back to my house and we
were swapping spit like pulled the pants
off if she had a period a [ __ ] pad
popped up and I on the way back so Riley
came by the room but she's like what
happened that was quick you know as a
writer was a [ __ ] trip man but a lot
of people don't know that she stay with
me til Thanksgiving that was that so
that's crazy look I never I've never
heard of your story essentially like it
may be my time now if somebody like you
just go with a family member like the
next like I I'm shocked you didn't go
with your stepdad like it's just going
from friend's house to a friend's house
I had to loose of a life Lee I had an
open door of my house I came when I went
by I went I wanted to you know I had a
phone at a neck of this that cable TV in
my room my mom had spoiled now it was an
only child how the [ __ ] was I know
living in city make new friends transfer
high schools to live in a on the fourth
floor with no [ __ ] elevator wand with
mice in the apartment cuz one was a
cheap [ __ ] he left food out at night
like that I couldn't do it I couldn't
[ __ ] do it if I went and lived with
carmine carmine mangy be in the house by
nine o'clock you had to have [ __ ]
AIDS on your report card he would check
your eyes when you came home and he
breathalyze you you know and at that age
Li I was too [ __ ] loose it was too
late I wasn't gonna I gotta be home at
9:00 are you [ __ ] kidding me I would
go out to the line but in hindsight I
don't know I did the right thing I moved
with the Bender's I did what I want they
threw me out of a year and a half later
that was it
you never thought about moving in with
Ryder she looked at [ __ ] Long Island
Lee that's even father okay so your
friends weren't very important yeah I
was just starting to you know I just
you
you
you
for all you need shroom tech mean alpha
brain shoot export I am so impressed
with shrooms export I can't they cuz at
the time I'm dying when I'm [ __ ]
working out I'm doing some workouts
lately wait why's that has been barbells
and [ __ ] lately right that has been
phenomenal it's big because a [ __ ]
Schrute export I'm telling you right now
guys I'm a fat [ __ ] I'm 52 years old
I don't like energy drinks it's not an
energy drink you just feel like you can
live you know it's just a feeling
trust me when I'm telling you start with
alpha brain they got a money-back
guarantee it's like going to a Chinese
restaurant getting the pork fried rice
and that sucks why we moving forward
same thing with alpha brain start with
alpha brain from then go to shrimp
export or anything else that do you
might need the team [ __ ] enhancer the
testosterone enhancer they have things
across the board that can help you
mentally physically don't believe me go
to Hahnenkamm right now see what they
got if you find something you like do me
a favor go go to box and press in church
I get 10% off your order also they have
to stay on a program but gets delivered
right to your [ __ ] house you can't
beat that with a stick
understand me going on and see what
think I could number to my man
[ __ ] they phone me and [ __ ] I
ain't dragging TV calm making it happen
classic martial art films classic
old-school [ __ ] man of the [ __ ]
one-armed all that type of [ __ ]
go right now I am dragon tv.com pressing
Joey and get two free movies you
understand me every week there at his
stuff it's the 4k technology this guy's
got some [ __ ] crack-a-lackin' over at
iron dragon TV everybody loves a great
martial art film don't believe me go to
high-end dragon TV and get your two free
[ __ ] movie see how the website works
you're gonna love it
Nelda live.com you smoke to vapor you're
doing the [ __ ] things with the
blowtorch they got all your answers you
understand me if you want to go to bars
they'll do life for the people to
[ __ ] take you there that navigators
of debt go to nail their live.com look
at the vapor pen think I think it's 50
bucks if you press it Joe in the end
boom in the box you get 20% off which
makes it 16th up in disease you
understand because I'm $40 $40 I'm sorry
I'm the more [ __ ] up
I must paid 750 milligrams I've been in
for that savage go to nail the life.com
right now press their joy yes boom and
get 20% off also my main [ __ ]
I've been smoking to go out the whole
show tonight hit e-cigs the cigar I'm
telling it was times I was smoking I
guess it smells like a [ __ ] cigar
don't believe me again
in any six calm right now
they got sad e e cigarettes zero the 24
milligrams you quit with them or you can
just smoke eight milligrams of [ __ ]
nicotine and just control your nicotine
or get this beautiful cigar do guarantee
they have if you get 1200 puffs from
each [ __ ] product they got this thing
last three four [ __ ] weeks and what
does it cost twenty with twenty percent
off that's sixteen [ __ ] dollars that's
what this going ahead these things calm
right now impress and Joey's Church oh
[ __ ]
I get 20% off your first daughter just
to get the [ __ ] party started all
right
beside that our phone and give a
shout-out to my main man my main girl
Jennifer Jones she made a beautiful Joey
cocoa being made out of weed she put all
you all would you eat I love this girl
she had the best mouth in the [ __ ]
world oh yeah she's a great [ __ ] the
girl anyway thank you very much see you
Wednesday night at eight o'clock you bad
[ __ ] till then stay black this
show is brought to you by on accom go to
Anna calm and use code word Church to
get 10% off of all the great
optimization products like alpha ray
emergent immune trim to export also go
to iron dragon tv.com iron dragon TV is
a roku channel with all of your favorite
martial arts movies they're adding new
stuff every day please go check it out
with new 4k technology use cobra joey to
get two free rentals go to hit east XCOM
that's hit letter e cigs calm they're
tasting longer-lasting
the proof is in the vapor they have a
cigarette sandy cigars for you it's
Cobra Joey's church to get 20% off your
order and for all the oil and wax
smokers out there to get twenty twenty
percent off the premier vapor pen on the
market going to nail that life calm and
use Cobra Joey Diaz